on Monday Donald Trump signed an
executive order banning federal funding
for overseas abortions reinstating the
so-called mexico city policy originally
created by ronald reagan this is
terrific news it should be followed
swiftly by ending federal funding for
Planned Parenthood press secretary Sean
Spicer bluntly stated quote he's a
pro-life president he wants to stand up
for all Americans including the unborn
we can certainly hope that trumps action
on mexico city policy is not a one-off
and it shouldn't be because here's the
truth more and more Americans are now
pro-life as guy Benson of townhall.com
points out a new marist poll shows
eighty-three percent of Americans agree
with Trump's actions here fifty two
percent of Americans want to limit
abortion to rare cases another twenty
two percent want to outlaw abortion
after the first trimester under forty
percent of americans think abortion is
morally acceptable and there is no
gender gap on whether abortion is
morally wrong despite what the women's
March organizers would have Americans
believe so what's changed why are so
many Americans now pro-life because
science ultrasounds have made it
impossible for Americans to deny any
longer that abortion does not destroy a
human life ultrasounds show the reality
of fetal development heartbeat by week
six is a pretty obvious marker it's no
wonder that are reported seventy-eight
percent of pregnant women who see an
ultrasound of their child say no to
abortion so naturally the left wants to
end ultrasounds Planned Parenthood has
fought 3d ultrasounds for years that's
the amazing technology that allows you
to see your kids face before birth as
dr. L lokra of Planned Parenthood
recently said quote abortion is a hard
enough thing for any woman to decide
without the torture of seeing the baby
on an ultrasound screen torture how
about reality but according to the
pro-abortion left reality must be
ignored today the Atlantic ran a bizarre
piece by moira wagle titled in Orwellian
fashion quote how the ultrasound pushed
the idea that a fetus is a person which
is somewhat like saying how the
microscope push the idea that cells
exist or how the Hubble telescope pushed
the idea that there are stars outside
our solar system or how human eyes push
the idea that the Atlantic is fully
insane the fetus is a person an
ultrasound is a piece of technology that
allows you to see the person the piece
itself is actually even worse Weigel
writes quote what is a fetal heartbeat
and why does it matter fetal heartbeat
mesh
is are based on two assumptions first
that an ultrasound image has an obvious
meaning second that any pregnant woman
who sees an ultrasound will recognize
this meaning science does not bear out
either assumption well yeah it sort of
does Weigel science denial here is
pretty incredible having seen repeat
ultrasounds of both my children the
fetal development is clear and
undeniable and it is nearly impossible
to see such images without recognizing
that there is a child in there not some
random clump of cells Weigel might talk
to an OBGYN or two before declaring
ultrasounds vague and uninformative but
weibull goes even further assuring
readers that ultrasounds were primarily
a form of warfare against women rather
than a tool allowing doctors to identify
problems with fetal development as early
as possible this is direct quote from
her article now after the war army
trained scientists and army funded
laboratories immobilized the technology
turning away from the ocean toward
women's bodies ultrasound made it
impossible made it possible for the male
doctor to evaluate the fetus without
female interference yes really this is
the ultrasound it's it's a war on women
that's basically guy side note here and
when my second child is were my first
child had a heart issue that got fixed
after she was born our second child we
actually did an ultrasound of while he
was in utero to determine whether he had
the same issue thank God he didn't but
that would have been possible that
ultrasound let's war for abortion now
takes no prisoners science itself must
be fought tooth and nail if women are to
keep killing the babies in their rooms
it's not going to work I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
ah here we are and so much to get to
it's going to be an epic episode today a
good Trump bad Trump because finally
finally finally Trump's president so we
don't have to speculate any longer about
what he's going to do and what he's
going to say as president because now he
is and there is so much to talk about
because he's really active which is
great good for him he's actually getting
to work he's not he's not fussing around
so that's a good thing and he's doing
some things that I like him he's doing
some things that I don't but we'll talk
about all of that first we have to take
thank you to our sponsors over a legacy
box so for years I've been saying to
people that it is imperative that if you
want to ensure that your family memories
are preserved for posterity you actually
have to go preserve them you have to go
put them on a DVD or a thumb drive us to
make them accessible you don't want the
old tapes just moldering out there in
the garage well legacy box actually
makes that happen in affordable fashion
in safe fashion they're fantastic the
way that this works is that you load
legacy box up with all your old tapes
and films and pictures and audio
recordings and then you send it back to
them and you get it back in a couple of
weeks on a DVD or a thumb drive ready to
watch and share it's great for
anniversaries it's great for parental is
for parental birthdays it's really
fantastic over a quarter million
families have used legacy box already
and they make sure that all your stuff
stays safe you don't have to worry about
are they going to lose it no they're not
going to lose it they actually send a
series of labels and you slap the labels
on the on the actual items and then they
scan them in when they get there so that
you can actually see in what stage of
development various films and in
pictures are so it's fantastic fantastic
service you should use it beginning to
end obviously legacy box calm / been you
get a forty percent discount on your
order legacy box calm / bend make sure
you use the splash been so they know
that we sent you and also you get that
forty percent discounts instead of
having those unwieldy boxes of crap up
in your attic now you can just have a
DVD that has all of your family memories
on it makes things pretty easy if you
got a fire in your house and instead of
you trying to show up at which box after
box of old VHS tapes now you can just
grab your computer and run so that that
is a safety consumer is also a wonderful
Thank You legacy box calm / been legacy
box calm / bent okay so finally Donald
Trump gets down to business finally he
gets to work we're putting aside all of
the silliness over the
conflicts with the press and finally
Donald Trump is doing stuff so what is
Donald Trump doing well yesterday he
signed a bunch of executive orders and
now it's time for us to do what we're
going to be doing all all administration
loans and do some good Trump bad Trump
and the reason we do this is because it
is very important to note when Donald
Trump is doing things that are good and
no one he is doing things that are bad
there are lots of people who seem to
think that because Donald Trump does
some good things that means you should
never critique him when he does bad
things or wrong things this is not my
perspective you can make your own
judgments on what you think of Trump
you're an adult good for you and I can
make my own judgment but what I
certainly can do is I can tell you the
things he's doing that are good and the
things that he's doing that are bad so
you are more informed coming away from
the venture puro show every day so let's
play the theme good Trump bad Trump
let's do it so there was a plenty of
good Trump to go around yesterday yes
plenty of good Trump so Donald Trump I
by the way I always thought this was
going to be the case that Donald Trump's
first hundred days were going to be
filled with things that I liked and then
I thought he's going to go a little bit
off the rails after that but so far that
prediction is on track so Donald Trump
start off yesterday as I mentioned by
signing an executive order reinstating
the mexico city policy which means that
your tax dollars now no longer go to
organizations that promotes or perform
abortions abroad that's great that's
great is it a huge step it's not only
it's an enormous step but it's a great
important step good for Donald Trump on
that other things that he did yesterday
that were quite good he came out and he
said that he was going to cut
regulations he signed an executive order
that froze federal hiring in the
executive branch which is which is quite
good so here is the here is equipped
with him talking about it we think we
can cut regulations by seventy-five
percent maybe more but by seventy five
percent have in a certain way better
protections but when you want to expand
your plan or when Mark wants to come in
and build a big massive plant or wind l1
succumbing to do something monstrous and
special you're going to have your
approvals really fast okay sir and the
one thing that surprised me that I want
hear what you have to say but the one
thing that surprised been going around
and meeting with a lot of the people are
disabled and meeting with a lot of the
small business owners if I gave them a
choice of this massive tax decrease that
we're giving for business for everybody
but for business or the cutting down of
regulation if I took a vote I think the
regulation wins one hundred percent now
in one case it's hard dollars and the
other case its regulation you would
think that the regulations would have no
chance it's I've noticed anything like
it virtually everybody is happier with
regulation than even coming to Texas so
the regulations are going to be cut
massively and the taxes are going to be
cut away again so you're going to have
now incentive incentive to go okay so
good for Trump good for Trump this is
the kind of stuff that he was elected to
do good for him so this is another one
of his big of his big pitches okay then
we get to a little bit of bad well
actually you know a little bit more good
Trump level got two bedrooms so other
good Trump Trump apparently is now
looking to chop down the the
Environmental Protection Agency to size
he apparently has pulled the Center for
Disease Control out of some global
warming climate change conference I
don't know why the CDC is going to a
global warming conference in the first
place as far as the EPA thing apparently
they've gotten an agency action plan for
the EPS they're putting out right now
and it's great so a pet they're looking
at budget reductions they're looking at
five hundred thirteen million dollars in
cuts to state and tribal assistant
grants 193 million dollars in savings
from terminating climate programs 109
million dollars in savings from
environment programs and management
they're going to stop the Clean Air Act
greenhouse gas regulations so this is
this idiotic notion that Congress
somehow gave the executive branch the
power to crack down on carbon emissions
it didn't so he's going to stop that
which is great he's going to maybe issue
an executive order barring the EPA from
overruling federal permit decisions
unless in clear violation of established
law also a good thing and unless major
reforms of the agencies use of science
and economics are achieved EPA will be
able to return to its battle blazes
the establishment administration takes
office so they want to destroy the EPA's
ability to twist science in order to
push a leftist agenda all of this is
really really good stuff so good for
Donald Trump on all of this this is
really excellent okay now it's time for
some some bad Trump so unfortunately I
gave you the bad Trump face when I meant
to go trim face but here's a bad trumpet
so Donald Trump here's here's some
here's some bad Trump and this is the
stuff that I think is more controversial
because it pre stages a split in the
Republican Party all the stuff we've
talked about so far there is unanimity
among conservatives that this is good
stuff and cutting down the EPA to size
cutting down regulations to size the
mexico city policy all of this there's
broad consensus among conservatives
across the spectrum that this is good
and this is smart and this is stuff that
we care about and then we get to the
stuff that Donald Trump actually cares
about the most the stuff that Donald
Trump actually cares about the most is
the trade stuff right because he is a
populist nationalist and now here's the
part of the Trump agenda that is helping
transform the GOP from a traditionally
conservative party based on the Reagan
idea of limited government based on the
idea of social conservatism based in the
idea of hawkish foreign policy this is
the part of trumps agenda that really
has very little to do with conservatism
at all and we start actually with
something that I think a lot of trumps
most ardent advocates were pushing him
for but he's apparently now no longer
going to do so apparently Donald Trump
he let's let's just flash back here for
a second I was from promised and a lot
of Republicans pushed Republican
legislators to do this in twenty
fourteen Republicans promised they were
going to get rid of Barack Obama's
executive amnesties that they were going
to reinstate the idea that if you are
here illegally there's the potential for
your deportation Barack Obama signed two
executive orders the deferred action on
childhood arrivals program the deferred
action on parents of those children
those were his two big executive actions
with regard to illegal immigration and
Donald Trump lest you forget promised
openly throughout the campaign then on
day one he was going to get rid of daca
and DAPA here was Donald Trump back in
September saying exactly that cancel
unconstitutional executive orders and
enforced oh
of immigration laws we will immediately
terminate president obama to illegal
executive amnesty in which he defied
federal law and the Constitution to give
am nity to approximately 5 million
illegal immigrants 5 million and how
about all of the millions that are
waiting on line going through the
process legally so unfair so Donald
Trump said that way back in September
now here's what happened yesterday Sean
Spicer came out and he said this is not
a top priority he said we're not going
to get rid of these executive amnesty
excuse me we're going to leave them in
place we're going to make sure that we
pass some legislation that fixes the
whole thing more basically going to
leave them in place that was not his
pitch during the campaign and here is
the problem what this now creates is
more of a magnet to drive people north
of the border which is what from
contended during the entire campaign
Mark Krikorian who's a big Trump
advocate needs at the Center for
Immigration Studies his big piece up and
national review today talking about the
fact that this is actually a big walk
back by Trump this is Mark Krikorian
politicians will always disappoint you
rich tells the story of how during the
few hours he was considering a run for
New York City Mayor he found himself
already starting to waffle on principle
to a potential voter in the elevator if
I were ever so unwise this to run for
office I too would no doubt disappoint
those who unwisely voted for me I was
fully prepared for the Trump
administration to do some things I
wouldn't be happy with but I expected
the problems to arise in the area of
foreign worker visas the president while
running for the nomination made lots of
statements about that what I did not
expect was for Trump to break an
explicit promise regarding his headline
issue on the administration's first
business day in office but that may be
what's happened and then he quotes
exactly what we just showed he said
immediately terminating the program
wouldn't necessarily have required an
executive order nor would require
rounding up and deporting Dacus ice has
enough to do already but ice right the
Citizenship and Immigration Services
which handles the two-year renewable
amnesty program could easily have
stopped suspicious
processing data applications both for
renewals and first-time applicants until
further notice but that has not happened
instead USCIS said we are still
accepting and processing daca request
under existing policy so the way dackel
works as you send a paper into the
government you can i'm here illegally
and now action on you is deferred Trump
could have caused that program he's not
right now there are 800 illegal aliens
receiving work permits during the first
business day of the Trump administration
and despite the fact that suspending the
Jacka program would simply require a
memo to the USCIS it's at least possible
that this is a snafu there wasn't that
much of a campaign infrastructure
there's time to do this still or it
could be or it could be that runs
Priebus and company were able to
convince Donald Trump that it's
politically unpopular to get rid of daca
and to target the quote-unquote dreamers
and so Trump is leaving that in place so
that is bad Trump that is not a good
thing other stuff that is bad from so
you remember the Donald Trump promised
and he's been promising for weeks that
they were going to move the Israeli
embassy the embassy in Israel to
Jerusalem here is Sean Spicer yesterday
doing his press conference basically
suggesting that this is not going to
happen we are at the early stages of
this decision making process not whether
it's when and how high there's a reason
you go through a decision making process
and that's what we're in the process of
starting right now okay so when they say
they're at the beginning of the
decision-making process there's no
decision-making process either do it or
you don't he promised he was going to do
it he's not doing it that is a walk back
so that's that's other bedroom I think
the biggest bad Trump is something that
is very controversial among Republicans
and that is this free trade stuff so as
you know I'm an ardent advocate of free
trade basically because free trade makes
people on both sides of the trade better
off now there may be people who are
disadvantaged by a free trade namely the
people who are not competitive in a
global market and those are the people
that Trump is pandering to so yesterday
Donald Trump issues he writes a memo
basically saying that he's going to
revoke TPP right he signed an order with
join the United States from TPP and he
said that this order was dedicated to
the working man right this is this is
the way that he phrased this it was
dedicated to the working man and this is
part of his broader anti free trade
anti-capitalism free trade is just part
of capitalism folks it if you don't
believe that free trade is part of
capital
I suggest the boycott every business
with which you actually do business
because you want to make yourself richer
it's not going to work Donald Trump told
business leaders today that they have to
make their products here or suffer a big
border taxes clip 15 if we can play that
the one thing I do have to warn you
about when you have a company here you
have a plant here it's going to be an
Indiana or it's in Ohio or it's in
Michigan or it's in North Carolina or
Pennsylvania do you have 50 great
wonderful governor's to negotiate with
so it's not like we're taken away
competition but if you go to another
country and you decide that you would
have closed and get rid of 2,000 people
or 5,000 people I tell United
Technologies was an example with carrier
and I got involved you know two years
after they are now so in all fairness
that was couple United Technologies was
terrific and they brought back many of
those jobs but EVP and he wants to kill
TPP now I've said the TPP should be
renegotiated because Obama negotiated
the thing and Obama had all sorts of
secret clauses apparently that contains
a bunch of provisions that Americans
don't like it should be subject to
Senate approval it shouldn't be the sort
of situation where the president just
gets to go sign a big trade treaty the
sentence should have to actually approve
it I believe in how the Constitution was
meant to work those are procedural and
content aspects of the TPP I don't like
Trump is just pulling us out here is why
this is silly what this ends up doing
China was not a party to the TPP Trump
says run competition with China trade
makes the people who are involved in
trade better off so instead of us now
having a big regional trading bloc in
the in the Pacific now China is stepping
in and China is now trying to create a
reverse TPP with all of the countries
that we were trying to create a free
trade agreement with so we killed our
own free trade agreement in favor of
bilateral trade agreements which are
harder to negotiate and organized in
certain ways and don't create these
these vast free trading swathes instead
now we have to negotiate with
Philippines and now we have to negotiate
with Korea and I have to negotiate with
each one of these places bilaterally
they have less interest in doing that
than they would in being able to have
access to 10 markets just having access
to one market China is extremely happy
today so really you'll go with the
Chinese newspapers
saying and they are ecstatic about
Donald Trump getting rid of TPP the
other group of people who are ecstatic
about Donald Trump getting rid of TPP
with no plan to replace it really the
other group of people are union leaders
now I'm old enough to remember when
Republicans were skeptical of union
leaders like Richard Trumka and people
to you aw and all these various unions
that had signed bad union contracts and
help the bankrupt American business I'm
old enough to remember when that was a
problem but now these Union folks are
coming out and praising from to the
skies and the Republicans are so yeah
that's great now the unions are on our
side well the question is what did you
have to give up to get the unions on
your side what you had to give up was
the American consumer well you had to
give up with some points of growth in
the American economy well you have to do
with sacrifice certain interest to the
interest of union so now we're pandering
to unions in the same way the Democrats
pandered unions Democrats Panzer to
unions by using the National Labor
Relations Board nor to cram down bad
deals on companies and Republicans
pander to unions with massive tariffs
and with anti trade regulations that
allow unions to make a buck off the
American taxpayer without actually
creating a better product here's the
union leaders out there yesterday
praising Trump 3 million of our members
in the United States was nothing short
of incredible and we will work with him
and his administration to help them
implement his plans on infrastructure
trade and energy policy so that we
really do put America back to work in
the middle class jobs that are members
and all markings of demanding thank you
very much and our people are saying yeah
win win win because all the union
leaders are on our side yeah except for
the fact that these union leaders are
what made American business
non-competitive in the first place in
many ways which is leading to these
tariffs which are impoverishing American
consumers you want to know why carrier
shifted jobs down south is because a bad
union contract it wasn't because of
global competition as much as it was
because of those bad union contracts
Trump is helping out those unions but
he's not helping out the American
consumers I know there are a lot of
people on our side who care more about
winning than they do about you know
basic principles but the fact is that
winning requires you to win on behalf of
a principle so I'm not sure what
principle it is that that Trump is
standing for on this one again the
reason that it's good from bad Trump is
because he's doing some good stuff and
he's doing some bad stuff this is just
the thing he's doing that he's shifting
the Republican Party in
nature of it we'll talk more about the
shift in the Republican Party in the
nature of the Republican Party we have
to we have to quit facebook right now I
just can't quit you but I can we have to
quit facebook unfortunate i'll go over
today lee weyer calm right now and
subscribe 8 bucks a month and you'll
subscribers still get a free signed copy
of my book for allegiance and i have
another book that's going to be coming
out pretty soon that that is going to be
available for a discount for subscribers
daily wire.com to check it out plus be
part of the mailbag in a couple of days
and you can send your emails and now to
be part of the mail bags and watch the
rest of the show live and opinion we're
starting to shapiro store anytime now so
all those goodies will be available
daily wire.com to join the most popular
conservative podcast in America
[Music]
you